[Musique]
faux
tout là-haut dans l'espace parmi les
étoiles et les galaxies
il existe une étrange petite planète
carré et cette planète s'appelle auguste
c'est ici qu'habitent moi tout à tous et
7,3 petit ami comme ils peuvent se
multiplier et se transformer à l'infini
ils voient tous n'ont pas de problème
pour s'amuser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez et moi tout va tout sans
transformer en planche à roulettes et
ainsi tout le monde peut jouer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est comme ça que depuis toujours
ils passent leurs journées
[Musique]
tout allait bien sur cette planète
quand soudain un matin une capsule
spatiale deux oies ou plutôt deux oies
ce trône hot 100 aux commandes
gracieusement la capsule amorce sa
descente
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe monnet se
côtoient dans une machine à laver là
dedans
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce
qui se passe dans l'espace
[Musique]
rapidement l'alerté donnée il faut
d'appeler le président alors voilà quand
m
[Musique]
aie aie la capsule est dégagé
bien voilà elle revient vers la tête
regardez et des montagnes et
[Musique]
ah ah
et c'est ainsi qu'un beau jour watou à
tous est arrivée sur la terre
mais
et